welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
trying to decouple with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we're gonna begin with
a deadly car crash in England that has
led to a diplomatic standoff with the
u.s. Harry Dunne was struck and killed
in August and police say they were about
to arrest a US diplomats wife in the
case but that American was allowed to
leave Britain under diplomatic immunity
MTS ty Abbas outside the US Embassy in
London in tears what's the victim's
family saying
yeah good morning Tony all eyes are on
this building here following Prime
Minister Boris Johnson's comments where
he not only identified the American
woman at the heart of this case but also
was urging the US authorities to send
her back to the UK but in a statement
from the embassy that we got a little
bit early they said to us and I quote
here given the global impact such
decisions carry immunity is rarely
waived before Harry Dunn's family that's
just not enough Charlotte Charles and
Tim Dunn are in agony not only have they
lost their son they say a legal loophole
for diplomats and their families has
also robbed them of their ability to
grieve if it wasn't for her being under
this supposed of diplomatic immunity it
would have been a clear-cut case we'd
have had justice by now and it's just
all turned into an absolute nightmare
for us their nightmare started here on a
country road just outside Royal Air
Force Crowden a US intelligence and
communication space that's where the
family says American and cyclists the
wife of the US diplomat was driving down
the wrong side of the road when she
crashed into Harry Dunn's motorcycle
we've just been left to just expect to
just accept the fact that she's got this
diplomatic immunity and swept under the
carpet right or wrong it's complicated
says law professor David Glazer
diplomatic immunity has been agreed to
by States in order to protect the
ability of their diplomats posted in
foreign countries particularly those
countries that might have more corrupt
or less scrupulous legal systems than
ours
Prime Minister Boris Johnson this
morning urged the u.s. embassy to
rethink its decision I do not think that
it can be right to use the process of
diplomatic immunity for this type of
purpose and I hope that answer Kulas
will come back small comfort for two
grieving parents where do you want to
take this how would where does this
where does this need to conclude do we
want to get a back we want some
acknowledgement from that
she's foremost full now the Dunn family
is considering legal action but their
options are pretty limited either they
can pressure the UK government to submit
an extradition order or they can sue the
US government for damages Anthony MTS
Tayyab in London thank you for very
difficult for that family I feel for
that don't we do you also can understand
though when you're in a foreign country
driving on the wrong side of the road -
it sounds like it was a terrible
accident but I certainly feel for that
family you have to